hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a new home starring me
markiplier this is a fan-made game about
me and I'm guessing it Bobby moving into
a new home using the gazillions of
dollars he made from his videos youtuber
markiplier decided to purchase a new
house after gyrating and undulating a
good bit he's settled on a nice home
there are rumors of spooky stuff like
ghosts ghosts II goos and demons but
markiplier ain't afraid of nothing
except maybe mannequins and dread halls
on a few other things who's keeping
score so he packed up his belongings and
moved in we join him now on a day that
began like any other well as you all
know I would definitely pick the haunted
of houses haunted this disk of houses to
possibly live in hello oh man day six in
the new house still feels a little
strange but I'm starting to get
comfortable in my new home oh I reek of
sleep I need a shower
yeah it's something I say in the morning
yeah that's my favorite thing to see the
first thing in the morning with this
body I can do anything I'm really
egotistical and narcissistic my favorite
shirts I'll have to replace them soon
enough this is my manly man muscles keep
tearing him oh I know it's a daily
problem I suffered this guy knows me so
well
the chest of drawers falls on you and
crushes you just kidding ok just kidding
you're safer now yes screw you game oh
you gotta put the rest of this stuff
where it belongs
soon oh gotta put the rest of this stuff
where I belong soon Oh put the rest of
there belong soon I'll get to this pile
of gifts from my adoring fans later
being so popular it's exhaust I'm not
this narcissistic oh this is one of my
million gifts of my fans have made for
me the mustache was a nice touch I mean
it's true my fans do give me lots of
gifts some like when I'm back when I
used to do the PIO box stuff and I used
to open it on camera but people send me
tons of stuff and it was great but
there's so much stuff and people were
sending me stuff just to get on camera
but either way I do pre
guys aren't you glad I took the time to
type out something you could already
plainly see yeah I wasn't paying
attention but whatever all right what do
we get in here oh the bathroom to
support Celyn grave from its past I've
never heard it referred that way that's
really funny
it's an assortment of bathroom supplies
would you like to wash your hands of
course maybe unless this kills me
somehow squeaky clean okay good maybe
I'll need to wash the blood off my hands
later keeps my hair looking this amazing
not really I just have permanent bed
head all the time now what close the
curtains first you want to show all of
youtube your pixel penis well I mean
they'd enjoy it I guess but maybe not
probably not no way what if it's just
like permanently like Japanese porn is
he's you unzip and it's just complete
block of censor like The Sims totally
like normal is like what you're weird
you don't have this okay whatever
singing in the show gotta make sure to
scrub my glasses squeeze yeah cuz I
bathed them my glasses all the time much
better
all that scrubbing has made me hungry
okay I should grab some grub from the
kitchen all right I'm so manly with all
my mouth who's who let me strut over
here but I like wristbands or those
likes like Goku's training weights so it
always keeps me nice and buff nothing in
here that would be any use to me nothing
here any use to me is a phony I don't
need to make any calls at the moment so
I gotta find the kitchen oh here's a
kitchen fancy that
no drug minecraft videos today I will do
drunk minecraft videos very soon though
I am going to get back into rhythm where
I'm able to record with Bob and Wade and
also I've got a ps4 with the Grand Theft
Auto don't look so surprised buddy
oh here's okay it sure would be useful
to take this knife along with you oh but
you know that's never an option well I
mean this is my house there isn't a
single dirty dish
cuz I don't own any dishes why did I buy
so much bread brown eggs are high in
protein pretty sure white eggs have the
same
Mount remember kids keeping your dishes
clean it's very important I guess why
did I buy so much bread see what we got
in here meat meat more meat I'm about
tired I'd never get tired of meat I love
me I could go for a nice salad or
something is that a joke that's better I
guess I should take a sit in my big
chair before I get recording what all
right whatever huge hat would that
always knocked over who knocked it's
over didn't even notice it's knocked
over when I came in oh well I'll worry
about later no that's not something I
wouldn't worry about I would notice that
immediately this is my big chair huh let
me just date my joy I don't have a
journal I'd have a diary okay now I'm
ready to record an episode or two oh my
god it's so mad I'm gonna play a game
where I'm recording videos while I'm
recording a video about games about me
me playing games SI saket gifts from my
fans so far neglected oh my god
it's a letter from a fan he knows your
full name and birthday and everything
what a creep well pretty much everyone
knows my full name and birthday my full
name is mark Edward Fishbach I was born
June 28 1989 everything else you'll have
to look up okay
record away all right then click which
game should I play today super spooky
submarine demented hospital 12
Slenderman slightly different version
yeah it sounds good hello everybody my
name is Marla welcome to damn it damn it
all annoying me in the middle of my
recording session I'll have you know I'm
very important in certain circles and
politics oh who could it possibly be at
this late hour morning early whatever
hey it's calling back to check in since
you were busy last time are you like
anything out so far I'm busiest time to
okay cuz I produced of my friends too
she's sorry you've been awfully staying
off this since you moved into that new
house I feel like you need some flat for
Leslie
fresh air want to meet up later
maybe another time I gotta go bub what
am i Wolverine now and never call if
anyone bub it's Bob now I have to start
that whole recording over again yeah cuz
you got so much good solid material in
the first time around some dudes
representation of me maybe maybe that's
the point no no ok let's try this again
wait new message let's see here dear
mark blah you're my favorite youtuber
I've been going through some tough times
blah blah oh come on man whatever back
through that's so mean
hello everybody my name is markiplier
well oh no oh
dinkus damn it the power went out I'll
have to check the generator in the
basement cuz that's a thing people still
have nowadays their own generator how do
I get to the basement
I imagine probably down this other
hallway I'm I'm not like this I promise
you guys I'm not like this no need to
visit the library ok maybe it was at the
end of this hallway
look oh yeah you had to check this one
too thought maybe it would have seemed
even more exciting than last one yeah
because I like to explore the games that
are played go home school you're drunk
that's not something I'd say weird
message F cool I won't be sticking my
hand in there like someone turned it off
must have been the yeah the basement
wind it rushes through oh boy dammit why
didn't it work well because you're about
to be haunted and murdered alized the
fuses are gone the wind must've blown
the map to how to find them so I can
record looks like there should be 5 in
total what is this an indie horror game
oh I guess there could be a fuse in here
crawlspace there's a big-ass crawlspace
oh I saw that
what is this pac-man views ah found the
fools and there's a giant hole in the
ground I really need to get this filled
in this is a crawlspace look hi I will
have that body for myself you won't keep
it from me okay you want this party get
in line
I'm gonna rip you out of it when I catch
you oh that ain't good
oh I'm dead you shouldn't have messed
with me you bets
god dammit how am I supposed to get away
from that I'll owe you y'all show you
huh
I'll go around the circle okay la blah
blah you ain't gonna give me I'm gonna
yeah okay I I missed I messed up there
okay hey I got this I can do this I can
do this I can do this I promise I can do
this I can probably do this where's is
Bologna salami I don't know these are
good jokes
I can tell you that come on yep in
pooper this guy's hard it's so tough I'm
gonna get him though okay so I got to
lead him all the way around but I just
got to be like more in tune with what
I'm doing I guess that's it that's it
that's it yeah yeah yeah back off buddy
boo bub
whatever your name may or may not be I'm
gonna go save cuz goddamn whoa Oh her
turret my house what's going on here ah
maybe something's going on
there are foods in here phousi foods hmm
I actually don't have that much in
actual physical game collection I don't
collect things in general like I really
don't I don't have collectibles or at
all
Wow what's this on the floor slippery
ghosty goo gross can't quite reach the
top maybe a kusum's ooh sure oh how
about this stool over here this seems
important yeah
I'll slide it in this goof I push it I
mean I could pick it up but that would
ruin the puzzle right oh it's like goof
true but I just broke it then I have to
poop have to reset her or something
there we go okay ha ha okay ha okay
there you go ha okay then not quite yet
go that way gotta go this way first then
ah [ __ ]
it's gonna take me a while I didn't
realize this game would be so full of
puzzles and then I'd be stuck over and
over and over again oh boy I thought
this was gonna be like a shorter game no
my beautiful clock I don't own a clock
alright oh yeah it was just that way I
was like I don't know I didn't see that
before yeah I'm so stupid
okay I should be able to reach it yeah
one more Fu's
I gotta get gone I gotta get moving I
got a buggy out I got it wait I gotta
save first
save alright go go go go we don't have a
lot of time we gotta move we gotta move
move move move down the pier I'm Mario
iron unicorn hole is the greatest thing
that ever again hole unicorn hole cuz I
play cornhole before hmm I don't think
that was as dirty as this guy was trying
to make it out to be but did I get a
Fu's
I may have gotten a Fu's not sure though
oh there's probably some sick references
in there I should I'll try to come back
to that later when I can find the fuzes
although all this blood come from
oh sure oh what happened here I just saw
that thing down there hello how are you
kind of creature is this and what
happened to it is it dead are you sure
there's a fuzz in its chest
I think it's tan but I will have to
stick my hand in there all right yeah
sack up not markiplier reach inside the
cheese yes do it
I would dive in there found it how did
he know who's in there in the first
place how would you been able to see it
if you had to dig around and find it but
now in the hands of super gross it smell
like rotten meat well I have to go take
a shower
yeah hello there I'm gonna go back in
the library now real quick my hands are
still super gross but I want to make
sure that I didn't avoid anything else
books on everything from locating the
blacksmith to bla bla bla bla books oh
no okay so these are all the same but
these are probably different pass about
which you stole the body of her young
friend and then left her to die this
book came from shelf seven steps to the
left one two three four five six seven
there's a button behind the book where
it's been taken out press book okay
passage about school in which was sent
into a terrible dimension as a result of
mystery girls malice this book came from
the shelf six steps to the right huh
button behind the book yeah but oh yeah
buddy bud oh girl lost inside the
demanded art gallery this book came from
the shelf eight steps to the left Abba
Dabba Dabba Dabba dubba dubba dubba
dubba dubba boom boom there's a button
behind the book
why fearing him boop-boop
ah dingus dings damn it
okay I gotta put him in the right order
okay dad I have that six No yay what did
i do well something happened okay what
that do yes yes I knew it
ah whose half out of whose I really need
to find out what this room is about when
I get a chance
how about now how does even follow her
crush some unsuspecting douchenozzle
okay so basically all those books down
in the other library were referring to
other RPG [ __ ] games that were made
that I played EEB the witch's house and
also me Sal all great games like if you
haven't checked them out already please
do they're great okay so there should
just be one last Foods but I said that
I'm covered in meat juice so now I need
to take a shower I think he'll just take
a quick shower so I won't smell like
that demon thing
it certainly won't come I heard that
overuse Slenderman jump-scare is there
something in here with me when he comes
in here I'm gonna stab him in the butt
over and over until there's blood and
poop all over you
gross I'm crazed muhaha uh-oh I better
forget the shower and focus on getting
out of here
I'll make a run for it when I have a
clear path yeah oh I didn't know that
would alert him your butt is mine okay
yeah that's that's not a not pro enough
yeah good thing I saved right before I
came you gave me a try again before
douche dick game's douchey and dickish
okay hop in
oh no Slenderman jump-scare blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah taking showers
no longer enough sand have to preserve
my weight don't know
thank you get out of here yeah yeah what
are you doing in my basement
get out here I'll get out of here what
this is baloney malarkey get out of here
up up go up
what is this baloney
well I can't escape if you're just gonna
stand there you dig oh this guy this guy
this guy that's where this guy this guy
by sucks maybe ice he went up before no
no go away you're not needed here
oh okay all right okay so that was my
opportunity to go well I won't be going
back here but my hand stinks so much hmm
I don't know it's rub them over the
adoring letters that your fans gave you
you a-hole yes
this guy's is is okay there's I think
there's just one Foos left it's one of
the millions gifts don't trust this
thing anymore favorite shirts you can
hardly see myself you're breathing from
inside the hole in the wall that's
creepy
when may have blown into this lockbox
but what was the code
oh I remember now I said it to my
birthday but I seem to have forgotten my
own birthday that's Noble I have to find
a way to remember what do you mean have
to find a way to remember it I know my
birthday what about one oh I have that
body before the day is finished I swear
you've already lost don't you see that
ah not really watch out for the wolf
mark may have poor eyesight but it will
find a way to get you what does that
mean I don't know what that means what
about the wolf what wolf is gonna get me
what wolf is gonna get me oh I didn't
know wait did I save I think I might've
saved goddamnit with this thing this
douchey ass thing is piece of poop God
screw it this is just a bunch of poopy
poop
bla bla bla I can't remember my own
birthday blah blah blah
why did it give me the chance to reset
the first time but not now Oh blah blah
the wolf is gonna get you on the crib
what yeah alright I think that's a
different the other guy was dressed in
black this guy's got some white so I
think there dude every beetle but I'm
not entirely sure I know that I gotta be
close to the end of this game I did not
expect this to go this long thank you
thank you sir okay so I gotta find a way
watch the blood on my hands oh no the
wolf smell blood and yeah maybe there
was like a sink in the kitchen that I
could use in Lusaka is still there I'm
gonna just real real quick real quick go
go go
come on come on come on dude dude okay
what what in the world he almost killed
you right there in there is such a
rabbit let's that's Wade Wade help me
Wade you're my only friend you won't
survive tonight young you badges on your
toe oh wait um grab your game for my
annoying fan so screw you
marklar didn't talk that way you seem
awfully fresh lately you know how
find closure for yourself so do it all I
need to do is get the power back on so I
can record my name is Bill blood in the
air goodness what a bunch of poopy gay
makes me sad gaming sad games filled
with sadness it's just a crappy horror
game didn't break okay so the wolf
doesn't smell blood in the air but I got
to be careful because okay so basically
my birthday is on this note here this
creepy fan mail Oh creepy really love
your show god
I'll send you a cartoon twenty-eighth
now I should be able to open that stupid
little chest as he was inside thanks
random kid with know what this guy is an
[ __ ] I guess that's the point like
it's supposed to not be me but it's
still like oh come on okay so I'll open
this that teddy bear looks like he's
angry now I've got you a Foos what's
this something seems off well that's not
right what happened my reflection so
hideously ugly it broke the mirror in
Twain
alright can I get in that chair save
your damn game
stupid life though your poop knit your
poopy poop i forgot that i need to go to
the basement somehow what the wolf is in
the way I gotta go get some meat there
is meat in the fridge so there's got to
be a way that I get the meat and
distract the wolf to the point where
he's not gonna be able to come after me
gimme gimme gimme gimme
ah oh my face ah you ripped my face off
I got to be able to get this meat
because once I'm able to get the meat
I'll be able to give it to the doggy if
he won't be able to give me no more
go go go go go go go go
okay so there's got to be some other way
that I get by the wolfy wolf possibly if
I don't run maybe he wouldn't be able to
get me but I'm not entirely sure about
that because he doesn't smell my blood
whoa Wow
that is insanity wolf I don't know what
to do oh hi but is my value okay so I
what's not supposed to go back in there
well god I don't know where to go maybe
there's got to be like some other way to
go into the basement maybe through that
other room in the library that might
have been something because it said
something about needing to come back
there before so I'm assuming that maybe
there's like a hole in the wall that Ike
see
there was a hole in my bedroom where I
could feel briefly breezy maybe that was
I don't know god this game is running
way longer than I thought it was going
to I mean I usually like to finish these
things in one go but still don't think
I'll be sleeping through all this
madness well good you dickbag I'll be
back once I find where I'm supposed to
go oh oh [ __ ] okay
oh so I get it now oh I didn't realize
that me hitting the wood was causing
noise I couldn't quite hear it because I
don't have headphones on at the moment
oh okay I got I got so that's what was
doing it so if I walk carefully and not
in his line of sight so I just wait
until he turns around there we go okay I
got it I got it okay that's actually
pretty clever I wouldn't have figured
that out right away do it all 5 fuzes
left to reset the breaker oh hi I was
about to do something I beat your stupid
game now leave me alone this is not a
game you're not gonna get my body I
won't stop until I do
well hello I fell in a hole it's that
guy like the real me and I've already
been possessed as soon as I got in this
building I'm gonna go with ouch looks
like there's only one way to go okay
there we go oh I'm cornered there's no
else to run you can't take my body if I
don't let you you have to wear me down
first I have a lot of fight left in me I
may be new to body snatching but I'm a
veteran when it comes to dealing with
creatures like you do yourself a favor
and forfeit now will you accept defeat
yes
no I don't know which hell knows what I
probably should decide you're not
getting your body back I took it in I
knew it I knew it I knew it
I knew it now that's my favorite thing
to see in the morning with his body I
can do anything
ah got it see see I knew it I knew that
wasn't me I knew that wasn't me Bob hey
Bob what's going on Bob Bob Bob That's
not me
Bob forgotten my own birthday that's
normal right I knew that already god I
knew I couldn't bend that big of a dick
leave me alone blah blah blah
markiplier doesn't talk that way you
seem awfully frustrated I know I know
you're mistreating my friends and fans
you think I do what I do for money
and I heard that remark about wanting to
eat a salad I knew that was wrong I love
me meat in my mouth ha ha ha thought you
would that would upset you you go ahead
and call off your wolves and ogres and
but stammers you can't scare me I moved
into a new home I'm the new Magua you
record with pants on you're nothing like
a real me I'm too proud to be defeated
by you well I knew that I thought you
wanted me to do something different okay
fine I knew I should have picked give up
because that's what I wanted to pick I
just did because I thought the game
wanted me to pick that well screw the
real mark of art wouldn't make the right
choice or the first go because the real
Bakker Blair's big idiot oh yeah whoopee
is that my pet dog Lucy I bet that's my
friend forever
dooby dooby dooby dooby okay
blam ah Oh spooky come on come on come
on back come on back back
come on back I knew it wasn't me I knew
it couldn't be just this game decided
that it was gonna be a little more of a
dick than it usually was and I'm gonna
do that no I I I'm totally sure this
game is actually quite good like I do
really appreciate it it's really cool
angle to go around I mean the twist
ending I get because I am Marga bar I
would know that but still it's really
interesting okay give up fine take your
stupid body back it's too much work to
maintain this hair anyway it's really
not you've treated my friends and fans
like trash and I won't apply that you've
had your fun now get lost you'll never
make a new home out of my body because I
am way too pro to be defeated by you
blam now where was I well that's it well
at least you guys got to see like in
case you weren't getting it like the
whole wrap-up of why he was about except
party time
the next day market bought through the
front party invited all these friends
who the hell are these people get out of
my house haha
okay Bridey back buddy it was really
worth yeah like they would believe that
story I came all the way from Island to
help get you to your new home lot it's
better be an awesome party hey why do I
feel like I'll be blamed if anything
goes wrong today just don't do the
styrofoam oh that's Wade oh okay hey
Mark I have to admit I'm a little
worried about seeing you two place just
imagine the fan art will get now oh is
that yamimash I bet that's your man -
I'm a little upset that Jaques couldn't
make it out say he's my kazooie it's
jontron hey Mark I'm jerilyn my
boyfriend and I made this game for you
we watched a channel just about every
night over noon
thank you so much for a short time I
even had a big crush on you don't tell
your boyfriend that and did you notice
the music I hope so because John wrote
every note of it that's awesome I guess
I should say hi because my nephews Tommy
and joy because they're big fans of
yours too
so thanks for playing Markie poo uh it's
Mark II mu thank you I'm Eric I'm John
my girlfriend and I made this game for
you I hope you enjoyed it because we put
a lot of love into
I loved it if you really liked it we'll
make a sequel sometime before you go I
want to make a shout out to my buddies
Lyle he understood me to your channel
the first series I watched was the
witch's house and it's still a favorite
this game if you didn't notice his know
much too that game we made the whole
thing in less than a week from concept
to completion anyway thanks for playing
well thank you someone for making it it
was awesome
this was awesome thank you guys so much
for doing it and thank you for putting
so much work into it I mean I knew that
there was going to be like another way
about this but like that it wasn't
necessarily what it was
see I'm done I'm done with the game that
was awesome thank you guys so much for
making it thank you guys so much for
watching huh oh no I'm not that big of a
dick I I instantly recognized that
something was off because I'm playing it
obviously lovely so either way I'd look
at my mirror and I flex my muscles but I
wouldn't need a salad no wait he'll buy
actually I'd like salad they're not that
oh so much my body thank you all so much
for watching click the entities with
warfare games that I've done or check
the link in the description below and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye